[Music]
welcome back everybody so careful boys
we are currently off the record with the
lovely colleen lionheart colleen
lightheart hey
at this time we're gonna start
discussing what are some movies that you
actually like
that most people don't and what are some
movies that you actually hate that most
people do you hate
i don't know
i i don't know what people like but hate
or like like you ever been the unpopular
opinion during like uh a movie
discussion i don't have that i don't
have very many friends to have like
these two guys we'll be those friends
right now you're a friend
what do you think of the marvel universe
um i was ready to disagree oh come on
i'll tell you why infinity war is the
best movie of all time
[Laughter]
no i agree i didn't i did enjoy that
movie me too it's time it's the best one
out of all the best ones it's the best
one
i will say this i did not like the new
doctor strange movie yeah kind of mid
huh i've heard that i really didn't like
i thought it was like going in a good
direction in the middle and then the
ending just turned into a whole another
yeah what was that anybody's
heartbreaking i watched it even shorter
it was decent i didn't watch the other
ones that's why i can't really
i i can't come you watch the sequel yeah
you don't think you need to yeah
i just watched it
i did there there are a number of paul
thomas anders movies i hate like what
the master i hate that movie oh why do
you hate the master it was boring it was
boring i don't think it was good i think
what about king's speech i didn't see it
i also also didn't like uh
uh i didn't really i could i can't say i
like the newest one that he did the
licorice pizza oh really you didn't like
licorice pizza i wanted to like it
really badly couldn't do it what was
your gripe about it it wasn't it wasn't
good to me it was just boring yeah it
just didn't have enough necklace cage
aesthetically pleasing
i
that's about it that's it i like a lot
of content
i like i think i like too much but i
also forget too much to have an opinion
so then i was like oh man these movies
are yeah watch movies once each yeah i'm
like damn dude i know what happened
totally forgot i did not enjoy the new
blade runner like i think the
cinematography is beautiful and it's a
beautiful movie to watch but it was so
boring i turned it off in the first like
20 minutes it was it's rough oh i have a
question for you you like quentin
tarantino what did you think of hateful
eight you know what that's actually one
that i haven't watched wait is that when
they're the western one right and then
they get stuck in a cabin he directed
that or did he just produce that one i
can't answer that i thought it wasn't
that like a three hour movie or
something i need to see that super long
wow three hours huh so we don't really
watch the same movie so we don't watch
it
we all don't really don't watch them so
we can't have this conversation what do
you think of homework bound
loved it awesome honestly one of my
favorite uh talking dog movies were they
[Music]
no talking were just a kid and your
imagination was running wild
it was a silent film
[Laughter]
i always remember the porn michael j fox
was created for the mocaps places why
don't they do like earbuds and like
beverly hills chihuahua like those kind
of dog movies anymore i miss those i
wanna know why
because while they're filming them shits
somebody always wanders on the set
starts recording it and says animal
cruelty is that really that's exactly
what they gave me so much joy and so
much love for animals yeah that's just
that's what happened to the last dog
movie they did so they they had a they
were like filming this scene with the
dog in like water so they kept dunking
it
and then they had pete like peter signed
off and said it was cool they had like a
person on set like uh making sure
everything was safely done and then of
course 100 feet away some other random
person's recording from super far away
that goes viral before the movie's even
out i want to kick that [ __ ] out
that'd be so difficult to work with
animals on set yeah they're just so
unprofessional
[ __ ]
never on time they go to the bathroom on
set which is weird licking them yeah
never ready never professional
yeah
no what do you think about so you like
action movies what do you think about
mad max fury road oh okay that i love
you know i actually haven't seen that i
haven't seen it oh man okay is it good
is it worth it [ __ ] time what are
some of your favorite action movies
action movies um understand
certain movies for different reasons and
list those reasons um like it man's a
great function
oh my god thank you
fifth man
yeah what about the fourth one with mike
tyson i wait the fourth one for tyson oh
the fourth one i can't say i like that
one i like it because it was mike tyson
i didn't like it the psy was enough
donnie yen's very good i didn't like the
fourth one because i think the strength
of the first two is the emotional
[ __ ] connection you make the fourth
didn't have that i like that they always
hate japanese people in the in the
movies yeah i love that part too that
part yeah that's like a narrative yeah
that's historical can't go wrong you
can't go wrong with that narrative what
do you think about the john wicks some
scenes are great um
like the last one not so well the last
one
i didn't like yeah especially towards
the end it was i agree it was rough i
haven't even seen the last one you could
skip that the the best scene was the dog
scenes i think the best thing was um
the knife throwing where they're
breaking all the stuff and then all the
knives are growing i think that was a
little more creative yeah i like the new
taco top gun i haven't seen the new top
gun but i can't wait highway to the
danger zone
did they do it yep they play it oh [ __ ]
they played a lot of the same sound like
music like yeah
they even started it the way like last
time too it was pretty cool dude i can't
remember correctly but i feel like we
didn't all love joker i love joker
someone here didn't
who didn't like joker that's what about
the new batman
oh yeah it was a little boring i thought
honestly i also thought that movie was
gonna end four different times
yeah i hate when they say the end in
this yeah
i do appreciate that they took a
different take that it's more realistic
like you can imagine yourself be in a
world where oh except for that i like
this part i like the the eye pick yeah i
like that i like that he had like
remnants of the paint and i was like see
finally thank you are there any like
certified classics that like are world
overloved that you don't like kind of
like et or uh
you know we don't have any pretentious
film people here
they're usually the ones that are like
soul counter culture they're like i
[ __ ] hate titanic
it's like man you're a [ __ ]
about hearing that conversation with
like a cinema thing
i kind of hate titanic a little bit but
yeah but not not if i'm a little bit
what's your uh guilty pleasure movie
like something that people don't expect
you to like at all but you like only you
like it
only you like it yeah very few very few
three ninjas there you go that's my
shirt mega mountains josh
josh movie that i i'm aware that it
sucks
i can't help but like it it's called
bunraku like nobody's [ __ ] seen it
it's kind of an action movie thing where
he's like hunting down these assassins
he's a cowboy that doesn't have a gun he
just punches everybody because he
doesn't he doesn't use guns he has a
code against it he doesn't have one
oh you know what's been happening to me
so if i watch nostalgic movies
it makes me [ __ ] sad and i gotta turn
it off so like like all of my child
because i love doing this right so
sometimes i'm just like i'm just [ __ ]
stressed out i just put on something
maybe like ninja turtles or something
like because it's like childhood memory
[ __ ] michael bay one and then you get
sad from the feeling that you get by
being young again or something anything
that reminds me of
my life before two minutes ago
something happens where i'm like yo dude
[ __ ] this movie
but i'm happy damn two minutes you can't
really watch anything
[Laughter]
i can't watch any movies
no it's that feeling of nostalgia where
i go back to that era of when that movie
was playing and then i miss everything
about it and i gotta shut it off because
it's not just a movie it's like a portal
of me being in a theater or like
anything and i'm watching the screen and
i'm just like oh [ __ ]
oh i gotta go back to school i gotta do
my midterm or whatever you know you know
what's funny is that i i had waited a
long time to watch this movie but i
finally saw better luck tomorrow last
year really and it [ __ ] with me pretty
hard really because it was that it was
that it was so such a good
representation of what it was like being
asian american in like 1997
that it like [ __ ] me up and i was like
oh god like i was having memories that i
didn't recall for so long yeah those
flashbacks right yeah
like you're like on ecstasy inside of an
integra and you're just coming back from
electric daisy carnival when it wasn't
in vegas and then you're just like
[ __ ] going home at 6 00 a.m and it's
kind of like that actually specifically
i'm gonna watch that movie tomorrow yeah
joe telling ryan's nostalgia story's the
best
yeah it was a little bit like that
are there any other popular movies i
mean i love back to the future we watch
anything
i love one and two so yeah i could watch
him on repeat and without stopping and
just [ __ ] and piss myself
every two minutes
that's a popular steve green dog why is
it always one and two like like three is
like i never even watched three who's
watching three dude yeah i don't really
watch three i mean i always watch one
and two you know what i like to do
though is i finished two because two
ends it was such a cliffhanger that i
just i just start three but then i kind
of give up oh everybody does that but
the reason i stick with it is because i
just like to wrap up flea's narrative we
use a great narrative hey mcfly what's
the matty chicken
[Laughter]
and then at the end he gets hit by the
car it's very sad and he dies
peppers don't exist in that universe
anymore
dude flea was just in something he was
just in uh this obi-wan show he was i
saw him in there he was in that yeah
that's pretty cool
i liked interstellar oh
like the science of interstellar by kip
thorne is a book so the actual theories
of what they
did for the movie is actually
it's like sound effects
yeah you could fall into a [ __ ] inner
star bookcase
i thought that that was very believable
yeah oh tesseract bookcase okay
i was like that makes [ __ ] sense to
me yeah
the different dimensions and how
different dimensions would have
different rules like time would be
constructed differently in another
dimension and how that would be bended
or be able to reach another one
[Laughter]
as you guys were talking about i'm like
oh yeah that part's great and then as
you continue on i'm like i haven't even
seen it has anybody ever criminally
spoiled the movie for you yeah [ __ ]
infinity war bruh
really yeah someone spoiled it for me
you know they got dusted
yeah i was like because i saw it late
because i always see always i always see
the marvel movies late i'm a fan and
then i was reading youtube comments on
some video yeah
but it was but it was like for like a
ufc fight or something oh it wasn't even
it wasn't related at all why do people
do that yeah cause they're pieces of
[ __ ] dude and they should all [ __ ]
die
but it was like
sorry spoiler alert guys so i don't want
you i haven't seen it
you're about to be that person sorry
they're like dr strange and spiderman
die and i go oh
god and it ruined it for me but i still
enjoyed it that's how good it was yeah
it's very good one of my one of my
friends totally [ __ ] inception for me
i
expressed for so long that i wanted to
see this movie who did this to you some
guy from my crew how do you support that
movie i don't even know how it works
this is how he did it and it this
literally is the worst way he goes
it was toronto
he goes like i was like don't say it
don't say this guy loves to [ __ ] like
kind of toe the line and like teeter
along he's like no listen one thing let
me just say one thing i'm like no [ __ ]
don't say and he goes
he goes
but did it really all happen oh and i
was like that is the worst [ __ ] thing
you could say to me because now i'm like
the whole time you should be okay so
that's not really like shut up i need to
give a [ __ ] about this yeah yeah shutter
island somebody spoiled once upon a time
in hollywood for me how do you spell
that well all they said at the end was
like and this dude i loved that whole
movie spoiled yeah but not like the the
ending at least yeah because the made-up
stuff is not you don't know what's
coming yeah i didn't know what was
happening right and then he just
mentioned like oh dude the fight scene
at the very end oh that is stupid to say
you're right he goes he goes dude it
gets pretty crazy someone gets their
head crushed and i'm like
that is [ __ ] dumb to say and i think
that's why i didn't like the movie
because it's plus the bruce lee built to
not know why that would happen
because somebody spoiled the bruce lee
stuff to me and i was like i wanted to
[ __ ] see his ass get beat and be
surprised yeah what was going to happen
dude i wanted to see that yes
about that you guys remember the fight
club ending of how everything was
revealed somebody spoiled that for you
no no but imagine if someone did spoil
it oh
that that would [ __ ] the whole thing is
not real or the prestige
if someone did that to me i would
or seven seven's big seven spoil that
you're [ __ ] dude even whiplash if
someone spoiled that [ __ ] too oh
bro you know what's so funny i told this
guy
i think i mentioned to you like oh i
heard whiplash is a really good movie
yeah and i made the impression to ryan
that i saw it and then he goes hey man i
saw your [ __ ] favorite movie whiplash
and i go oh i haven't seen it yet i
watched it because of him i was like i
was flipping through i was like oh you
know what nick said this is a really
great movie i watched it just
misunderstood that it was his favorite
movie yeah i guess i don't know what i
was thinking oh i made the impression i
accepted his [ __ ] brain and that's
what you guys get for joking around
i returned to him as if i had like
completed his journey and i said hey
dude i saw a great recommendation he
goes i haven't seen you
and then do you think ryan's like and i
wanted to connect with nick and i don't
know and i go i'm deflecting sorry first
i find out he's not really gay and then
he always says whiplash you know what's
a classic i saw recently and i was just
like man this was good land before time
land before time's a hitter bro
all of them all of them you know
wait there's more than one bro
there's like three four and five yes
a lot of spin-offs what about tv shows
like series because seriously i've been
like taking it off in another direction
what you got what what what are some of
your favorite tv shows oh what's your
jam i better write these down let's go
cause i forgot to watch ozark all genres
ozark is great
yeah i haven't stranger things i've
watched that one
season four is pretty good you know
somebody just got me into the boys and i
will have to say season two is like a
as a wash
rally
you know what i've watched season one of
boys and i i realized i didn't like
season two either season two is rough i
was just naughty i think it was rough
about it it's boring like
it was people i think part of part of
the part of the allure of season one is
discovering what like what everything is
right and then once you already know it
all they don't do enough with the tools
that you already haven't played well
there's a lot of shows like that after
you break out like it's like what is it
hunger games once they get out of the
thing it's like that's what it is what
about love death robots oh i haven't
heard about that that's a great one
black mirror steve what's that one on
netflix that we were watching about the
kids that that are in a dormitory they
got magic
harry potter
neat yeah we like it umbrella academy
that one oh yeah that's a sick one i
like that one i haven't seen it though
that's not harry potter that's a hell of
a pitch joe i think sons of anarchy has
has a wall too i think such a sounds of
vanity has a very uh straight wall
because but do you like mr mayans i
didn't even see it because i didn't have
faith i didn't i know i didn't have
faith in it anymore because at a point
sounds vanity they just start lying just
to forward the plot where things could
have been fine but then for no reason a
character will lie yeah it's like why
why and what's their motivation that's
like a basketball just to like forward
the why would you say that that's what i
would say yeah it's like right after
they alleviate something it's like oh
well then you just [ __ ] the whole
thing up there
is anybody experiencing superhero movie
burnout yeah i think that's what it is
with the marvel stuff too i think for me
and not even just that but like the boys
and i should watch them all that stuff
i'm just so kind of sick of it i guess
yeah that's why you're just recycling
and recycling there's a point where it's
it's i just need a break yeah i loved
aquaman though that's how i feel about
disney movies but a long time ago like i
every disney movie that came out like
even the pixar ones it's like all right
basically i've seen it already do you
ever re-watch old disney movies and
think about the actual easter eggs that
are in those movies for the adults look
at the same stuff
all the dicks i'm not a fan of it i
don't like it
only that part that's the only reason
i pause it screenshot it and send it to
him you know what i didn't like the
newest best fashion cheers guess what i
and i
and i defend all the glasses too
it was so bad it was bad and i i i it
was probably the worst movie my heart
was ever seen because in my life my [ __ ]
is fast and furious because i love how
[ __ ] unapologetically absurd they are
and then this one was like what the [ __ ]
they crossed the line
was it too absurd or not absurd enough
it was a little bit of both in different
areas they should just stop making them
yeah it was like
it was um it's like they didn't
understand their own [ __ ] power at
that point okay if you took over the
fast franchise what would you change
about it i wouldn't now all right the
damage is done i've thought about this i
would make a two hour and thirty minute
movie where the only line of dialogue
vindis who can say his family and and
the whole time
but but like groot he has to say family
in different ways to express like groot
the amount of memes
[Laughter]
that's so fitting that it would be him
doing that too because it's layers
there's layers he could do it maybe the
new guardians out yet
guardians of galaxies there's rap
principle you know what i'm looking
forward to
i want to see elvis i knew you were
going to say that how did you know i
don't know i had a i like elvis you look
like you like elvis is it bad was that a
question i hated rapture yeah i heard a
lot of people didn't like it it was so
well done it was so dumb and it was
there's nothing going on with the biopic
movies where it's like no one would ever
like a band called queen it's like we'll
see about that but it's like very like
that never happened
i loved it but the filler [ __ ] that that
people would say to each other was so
non-creative like even just the stuff
that the daughter was saying like in the
beginning of the movie i mean if you're
gonna call your dad father already then
it's [ __ ] to me no one [ __ ] calls
her dead father but they're the not
pakistan but hello christian zoharians
still didn't work still didn't work now
uh really slept on film in my opinion
that i watch all the time is cop land
copland copland so much [ __ ] time
steven seagal uh no no cop is stallone
and it's probably his best acting role
ever really yeah he's greeting huh no no
this is coupling the movies right the
palma movie this is like oh man i want
to say 90s yeah yeah it was 90s but it
didn't do very well but it's a very
[ __ ] dope movie very good he's really
damn good in it i like demolition man do
you remember what about walker guys
watch that series walker texas ranger or
just walker well i mostly watch the
three corner buying
the new that's the the new one the new
one's really good is there a new one
off of walker texas ranger
yes but it's not chuck norris who is it
no it's the guy from uh blue mountain
state what's his name oh yeah yeah i
know you're talking about the jack
reacher guy jack reacher yeah oh the new
jack reacher the new jack reacher that's
what it is it's not walker jack creature
oh jack reacher joe okay yeah yeah why
is it good what's what's uh
that was just good writing good
storytelling good
after they killed glenn i was out yeah
me too you know he wasn't even supposed
to stay alive that long i don't care joe
i was he was already dead yeah it was so
dumb to do that but they kept killing
off all the favorites
segway though out of movies who would
you want on your zombie apocalypse team
none of you guys y'all are weak who can
i pick
you can pick anybody dead or alive can i
pick anthony and use him as a shield
[Laughter]
turn him into a zombie keep him on the
chain like
what's her name
there's two straps on his back and just
feel like that through the whole thing
probably tastes like the noodles at this
point yeah
i'll have zz top wait who would be the
one
who would be the first people to go in
this room
anthony
the people who don't have any like
survival skills
like they're in a career where it's like
you know social editors
then probably me i definitely don't have
survivor skills and i hate camping so
i'll just be like not peace i'm just
laying down here guys
that's like you yeah i don't like
camping would you where would you apply
your best as soon as the zombie breaks
in here would you sit on your ass just
wait for it to if a zombie comes in here
i'm like yo
yeah hell yeah are you ready
grapple let's go
so cinematic and then that zombie is a
black belt and he [ __ ] jokes that's
what he would do he was just like come
on i [ __ ] hate zombies come on yeah
yeah
yeah
no in my luck i get picked i get scrap i
get screw i brush up against a zombie
get scratched and i'm like oh i'm turned
now yeah that's my back
[ __ ]
a zombie coughs on me and i'm like guys
i'm not feeling too good of course a
zombie with a [ __ ] golf visor
they had two polos on you see that [ __ ]
jesus two [ __ ] they're the first to
go absolutely absolutely cause i'm just
lucky again
[ __ ] steve
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you